I think it's only right that I should
mention also those who have contributed
to creating a sense of urgency in
broader society because that's what's
driving us there was a huge sense of
urgency in European society that this
needs to be done it needs to be done now
and I think you have a boy on slap was
mentioned before you have the plastic
soup surfer you have elecman Ellen
MacArthur who was one of the first
sailing the Seas discovering the extent
of the problem you have the wonderful
wonderful Blue Planet series by David
Attenborough who had a huge impact on
public opinion you have the wide-ranging
media who've taken up responsibility to
create public awareness you have the
educational system that takes a
responsibility ability here you've seen
the force of the NGO community across
the European Union also creating the
sense of urgency academia has played a
wonderful role in finding new solutions
so I think if if we we are to say today
that it's quite remarkable that we got
here we have to also to be grateful to
all those outside the political sphere
who got us to this point